[Music]
hey everybody happy sunday
tom's just there like looking smug and
like drinking i came back from oasis
yeah he's been at the oasis like he
usually is i've been three days he's
been pre-gaming for the show yeah i mean
it's still technically the weekend so it
was fun
yeah it was all right did you have a
good time
why does this [ __ ] always happen to you
i don't know man [ __ ] it
that's funny did you like did you get up
on the i realized all those other dudes
calling me over
and i'm like hold on i'll be over here
in a minute i had some other [ __ ] i had
to do and that was what's up man and
he's like what's up i'm right here
what's up
i was like okay
oh i get it you want to fight
and he's an old dude all [ __ ] burned
out as i get it you want to fight and i
said how old are you and he got a real
real unconscious about that he got real
self-conscious and i said look man
you're nearly six feet tall
but i would [ __ ] you up you will come on
and do it and i said there's no reason
to because you think you think i'm
looking at you i'm not looking at you
and he goes no you yeah i see you you're
looking at me and it says no man that's
your imagination and i go eddie goes i
don't have no imagination and i well
that was that was a good answer
he started busting up laughing
and i noticed that when he started
laughing his all half his teeth were
gone and i said
and i said it says [ __ ] you're on making
you paranoid you think i'm watching you
i'm not watching you because you're not
watching me this is not you're like
that's the meth talk
yeah makes you think i'm watching yeah
yeah you might be right about that then
you want to be friends well see he
learned something yeah he might be right
this is i'm not watching you although
he'll probably forget it by the time he
goes home
it's in your imagination i don't have no
imagination
that was pretty good
laughing let's see
you don't have an imagination now
i'm not worried fair enough he thought i
was watching him yeah you let her know
yes actually i'm watching yeah i'm not
watching you dude i'm watching your sexy
meth yeah i'm not watching you and he's
like [ __ ] way way way back there he
thinks i'm watching him [ __ ] he's
looking at me
yeah thinking that i'm watching him
so yeah so hey everybody uh hey business
said jenny that blue wig is extremely
attractive thank you very much yeah this
is actually like i said i bought i have
like lots of different colored wigs i
have black ones and red ones and white
ones and [ __ ] like that but this is my
favorite one came up in here i saw that
blue wig i was trying to get some of
this it says i'm going to be asking
and then i was like and she's like doing
it no i didn't say that i said no i said
because i've had i've had other [ __ ]
get in this [ __ ] right now she's like no
i can't handle it see that's not what i
said that's how it is let me tell my
story that's my reality that's not true
though okay
okay i said because you're because i've
had a stomach ache for the last couple
days and i said and i said you're he was
like squeezing my stomach
i don't know if that's what it was or
not not those seeds or some other seeds
some blackberries
but yeah so that's kind of like
indirectly yeah like why because today
we were actually supposed to talk about
the untouchables because louie sent us
the untouchables like the steelbook yeah
but then last try to play it well last
time we went to watch it and one we
couldn't like get the disc to work so i
don't know if it just like needs to be
cleaned or if we shouldn't i'll
investigate it more yeah we'll figure
something out and then playing on the
xbox i gotta figure out and and there's
only only have one other blu-ray that
will not play on that xbox and it's the
descent
oh yeah that's right remember that one
and it was a british version of the
descent it won't play on it yeah so i
don't know why that steel book won't
play
i'm gonna investigate more on it yeah so
we might still be doing that movie but
then in a way it was kind of like better
because i was kind of like i was really
feeling too good last night like my
stomach was kind of hurting so yeah that
one would have been [ __ ] up so yeah so
i mean if i want to watch that i want to
like you know give it my full attention
and like it's longer and stuff like that
so tom's like why don't we just watch
jaws the revenge because you've been
like wanting me to watch that it's on
tubie and that one's kind of like short
it's fun i've seen it a couple times
before and i said i don't have to
concentrate too hard on it because i've
seen it and also it's kind of like a
stupid movie but an entertainingly
stupid movie you know what i mean i
actually i think
no i know that i saw jaws the revenge in
the theater
damn in the theater not only that i'm
pretty sure i was watching another video
but before and they talked about how
there was a novelization and the guy
that was doing the video said hey he had
read the novelization back in the 80s i
said you know what now that you
mentioned it i think i might have to i
think i might have read the novelization
of jaws the revenge
the [ __ ] was the matter with me
i suggested it because jenny said that
it had michael caine in it michael kane
and [ __ ] i'm a fan of michael caine
for some strange reason well i don't
like michael campbell i don't think
that's strange michael caine's a [ __ ]
yeah he's awesome yeah
and uh so
she's michael caine was in it and i was
thinking well it has it has a a
ocean theme maybe it'll be like the
maybe it'll be like the island or
something
it might have some of that in it it is
not like no it's not at all um it's not
as dark as the island
it really tries this movie really tries
hard to be a good movie it's actually
kind of well made
in some ways uh the acting is good it's
got a good cast
uh the score really
wasn't notable uh the edit was kind of
ponderous
in certain spots it kind of slowed down
and then actually the premise edited
like really [ __ ] up yeah yeah that's
what was going on really that well and
the shark
the shark the shark looks bad all right
kind of bad not as bad as the one in 3d
admittedly yeah but
i would say it's not a terrible shark
puppet
but they showed too much of it the
editing [ __ ] kana because man that
[ __ ] ass shark is out of the water like
oh yeah
yeah and it does some weird i was like
get back in the water shark what do you
you can't breathe up here yeah and it's
got [ __ ] home shark you're drunk it's
got a decent it's got the original cast
from shaw it's got a lot of the original
cast from [ __ ] jaws one no not really
just got bro just that one just that one
chick though is that it okay that's it
okay
okay well they fooled me into thinking
that more of the people were still in
they acted like they acted like you know
who who was [ __ ] yeah brody's
son in it yeah and he gets killed and
then his wife and uh
i want to say it's a weird mixture
because
it's not a terrible movie
it's really trying
okay it's just that
no i didn't recapture it
it's not steven spielberg
well that's that's one of the big
problems honestly i think the main
problem with this movie yeah um was not
the acting it wasn't the special effects
it wasn't anything like that it was the
premise it was the idea
it was a
big
idea
it's just a dumb idea it's got there's
too many like plot holes and i'm willing
to overlook
certain plot holes
like if the movie's otherwise good but
this one it just seemed like so many of
the problems could have been avoided and
oscar pointed out the same thing why
can't the brody family stay away from
the damn water problem solved that's
what i said like as soon as
you had jaws one and then you had jaws
two and then the shark was [ __ ] with
them again i'm like all right we're
packing up and we're moving to [ __ ]
nebraska or we're moving to somewhere
where there's no [ __ ] ocean
um and we're never going in the water
ever again easy
how's the shark gonna get you then it's
some weird [ __ ] the woman has a psychic
link with the uh brody's wife has a
psychic link with the shark she can
she's having premonitions when the
shark's coming it's like
my shark sense is going to be yeah
so it's got a paranormal [ __ ] it's
got some paranormal [ __ ]
trying to think what else is [ __ ]
[ __ ] weird about oh there's the the
fakest the fakest jamaican you could
ever [ __ ] imagine i guess he's
supposed to be a bahamian but say i mean
you know kind of similar whatever and
it's supposed to be like yeah that's
mario van peebles he was actually in
some good [ __ ] like he was in new jack
city right i think he directed you look
at him and you go man i know that dude
that's a famous dude [ __ ]
van people's was his name and uh van
peebles yeah
he's doing what they told him to do
uh you can you can tell he's star
material for far as an actor
but his accent isn't isn't all that
great and i would have never [ __ ] it
was a dumb idea to tell him to do that
they should have just had him play an
african-american guy there's no reason
why he had to be that's what i mean
because everybody else that was living
in the bahamas it's like you know
brody's son was like working down there
he was like so i was like why didn't
they just make him an american guy like
don't make it
like
yeah or or or you know they could have
actually gotten a bahamian actor to play
that role like they could have done two
if they had two options there
they had the one fake jamaican
underneath the ground he would have that
that character had been so much cooler
yeah
it's just he'd have been it's a famicom
he'd been a lot cooler if he was just
some dude from detroit that had been a
lot cooler that's what i mean i don't
really understand like if you have a
movie and it's not
central to the plot that that person
have a particular accent or be from a
particular country then don't make them
that just make them like whatever the
actor is and if you have to like explain
it away like oh they're an exchange
student or something like that just it's
a throwaway line it takes two seconds
you know and then you don't have the
whole thing of like here's somebody
doing this cringe-worthy accent that
they don't need to do
like through the whole entire example
example
in the thing the two black dudes in the
thing they didn't have to be some from
some exotic country they were americans
and [ __ ] you're just like yeah yeah
it was natural [ __ ] it was supernatural
it was it was super dad yeah murder
hornet said is that the one with the
jamaican guy yeah the yeah the for
making jamaica if i make in jamaica
don't just because you got a black dude
don't make him a jamaican in your
[ __ ] movie well like i said let him
be who he is and like i said if you
wanted that character to be from the
bahamas then get a new actor that's
actually from the bahamas it can't be
that hard uh there are lots of people
that live there and i'm sure some of
them are it was the thinking of the time
that's what i'm saying well it's like
well we need somebody that's kind of i
don't know if like mario van peels i
don't know if he was super super famous
well the thing about mario baby [ __ ] he
he was but i don't remember if that was
later like i know i know it was 90s i
know it was like new jack city and all
that kind of stuff i think that was 90s
90s now the thing about mario van
peebles though is that his dad is melvin
van peeble he was actually like quite
famous like in movies so maybe that was
that kind of thing but
but yeah so the only
the only like actor they got from the
first one was lorraine gary now they did
ask um roy scheider yeah now he was in
the second one he was in the first one
obviously and the second one they asked
him if he wanted to do jaws 3d and he
said absolutely not
and then they asked him to do this one
he's like absolutely not no now what
they were going to do initially they
asked him they said we don't have to be
in it in it but do you want to do a
cameo in it and then we'll have you get
killed at the beginning because actually
he was supposed to get killed instead of
the sun right
um and he was like absolutely not i'm
not doing it
so they're like okay well plan b we're
gonna uh have the sun get killed and
then now how many kids did the did the
brodies have in the first movie now i
can't even remember i don't even
remember because they have two sons and
here's the thing about the part four two
which is just called jaws of revenge
it's not called jaws four but
it doesn't it doesn't have any
continuity with the third movie
yeah because in the third movie the sun
works at sea world but he has like a
different kind of job but they're just
like like pretending that that whole
third movie didn't happen
so they're just like going pretend also
that jaws
yeah
i guess i can't blame them too much well
they're trying to like [ __ ] that was
like a [ __ ] jason movie it was very
much like a j jason in the water and
he's got finished okay i will argue that
okay 3d yeah jaws 3d i would argue is
actually worse than this one
um
but
it but at least that one had a good idea
i think that was just like a good idea
like a great white shark gets loose in
like a like a water park great that's a
great idea
um
but they [ __ ] it up they tried to make
it 3d you know the 3d looked
atrocious and they just whiffed it yeah
this one
if this had been a good idea this
actually would have been a decent movie
this one it's just the script was just a
stupid idea and there's like really no
way
to make a good movie out of that unless
you're making it a comedy and this was
absolutely not a comedy and it was
really serious and they were almost
trying to like hearken back to the first
movie and make it almost like a soap
opera and there was like all this
character development which actually
mostly turns out to be kind of boring i
don't remember two that well what which
one was two i haven't seen two in a long
time either now two was okay
like two was pretty good that had most
of the cast from what i remember it's
been years since i've seen it but that
had most of the cast from the original
one and you know obviously it's it's
straining credulity after a while which
like this one family gets like bothered
by the shark so it's almost kind of like
when you know they got to the fourth
where they're just like [ __ ] it we're
just gonna say that this family is just
like shark attractors and i think in the
original idea of this which i don't i'm
not sure if this would have made it
better or even dumber than it actually
was
was that
the whole thing about the shark like
targeting the birdie family specifically
was that it was some kind of like voodoo
curse
how do we feel about that
i mean i don't at least it would have
been some kind of explanation in the
movie they don't give any explanation
they're just basically like
because and it's like the shark that
comes after them
it's not is we're led to believe is this
shark like was was the other sharks that
got blown up like in the first movie was
that like his mom or
like that this was just a shark that
decided i don't like these [ __ ]
and i'm going to swim all the way from
new york all right into the bahamas
which is like 1200 miles let me go ahead
and nip all this in the bud before jenny
loses it
here was the problem
you have to understand the zeitgeist of
the day
in those days
you couldn't have a random shark movie
that
that genre had not been established yet
so if you're going to talk about a shark
it was going to have to be a jaws movie
but that really limits you they should
have never done that but
that was the thinking of the time
later on they realized you know we can
just make movies about sharks i mean
sharks are inherently scary right it
doesn't have to be a jaws movie
but they hadn't thought of that at that
time okay
because there had been some good shark
movies you saw them in the theater a lot
better water a lot better than this the
one where they were down the center 47
meters down and then and then like the
sequel where they were in the cenotes
remember that one yeah that was a good
that was that right there's one called
the reef which is actually pretty good
too and like i said open water is good
although that's only marginally about
sharks that's also about just being
stranded out in the middle of the ocean
and then and then there are sharks and
that's actually based on a true story so
i find that horrifying they're kind of
[ __ ] themselves with this movie
they want to make a shark movie
but they have imagined a limitation
they're imagining that it has to be a
jaws movie well there was a reason why
because jaws 3
even though it got [ __ ] on by critics
actually made quite a bit of money
you're right so and also universal
studios was opening up their jaws ride
and they wanted to promote it so they
said we're going to make another jaws
movie i would have [ __ ] and this
actually was still financially
successful
just because it was kind of cheap to
make i would have fought against all
that [ __ ] well yeah but i would have
told the studio execs that what it is
is they don't really give a [ __ ] about
the jaws and the
jaws series or anything like that what
it is they want they want they want
shark movies
and you could beat jaws one
if you were freed from the jaws
franchise
you could have done it easily made some
bad ass shark flicks
but they didn't think that way back then
um i don't know why they just weren't
very creative they were just you know
companies
uh you know corporate thinking i would
if i was an independent filmmaker i'd
have made a badass [ __ ] shark movie
kind of like the ones that you just
mentioned was it something 40 40 meters
down or 47 meters 47 meters down that'd
come up with a premium i said the reef
the reef open water right and you put
enough money behind the promotion and
you could beat jaws you don't need the
jaws title on it
and that's really what they're doing
here they actually spent money on this
movie
but they're not a lot but yeah they
spent money on it because because
actually some of the stuff that they did
was all practical effects it would have
been expensive to do
but i would have freed myself from the
whole jaws premise
and
made a [ __ ] story that [ __ ] beat
sharknado beats jaws in a certain way
but but some crazy [ __ ] like that
could not happen until cg happened
because there's just no way to do that
with practical effects
but still there's the example there was
a demand for for shark movies i would
have filled it the italians tried to but
they just couldn't well theirs were just
all jaws rip-offs they were jaws
rip-offs which to be fair like oscar
pointed out john's is one of the
greatest films ever so it's not like
you're really gonna top it necessarily
not in that not in spielberg's way
no
spielberg always brought a certain
amount of magic especially when he was
in his prime
you could feel that it was a spielberg
movie and that was really kind of what
made jaws
one great is that even though
it was in a way a horror movie
there was an
american
middle class positivity to that movie
like an acceptability it was like
american
ethno
ethno national propaganda in a certain
way it was like this is america and we
got a shark yeah it's just like that is
just the way that was well i would argue
too that one of the things that made the
first shaw's great other than being
really scary and like the suspense being
really good and everything like that was
it had great characters yeah like the
characters were all interesting they all
like i really liked like the interaction
between them and it's just kind of like
so you enjoyed hanging out with the
characters even when no one was getting
beaten by sharks right well that's what
i was that's kind of going back to
exactly what i said there was something
about the genius of spielberg and the
tone that he could set
this goes back to [ __ ] close
encounters of the third kind or whatever
he could put america and the american
people and the the american culture
center stage
like it's the place to be and [ __ ]
you can relate to it and [ __ ] we're
having a great time and there was
something about spielberg he was just
good he he'd have made a great
propagandist okay
because there is a certain feeling like
you're watching american propaganda
but it's entertainment though you know i
mean it's [ __ ] great it's just
there's a lot of good there's a lot of
great directors but i still i'm gonna
say that [ __ ] spielberg when he was when
he was running strong
spielberg is my favorite director
and i think a lot of people would agree
with me
and a lot of it had to do with the fact
that it kind of felt like propaganda but
it was it was it was feel good
type [ __ ] even when the
even when the even when the subject was
bad you still felt good about it there's
just something about it
lucas an idea man spielberg was a
feeling man he understood how to [ __ ]
tell a story i could watch i can watch
close encounters of the third kind today
and still feel like i'm
seeing that movie for the first time
and vibing with the characters yes just
like well like i said i think that's one
of his main strengths yeah is that he's
a really he's really good at
establishing characters that you give a
[ __ ] about yeah and that you want to
you're relating to them watch and that
you want then yeah and that you can
relate to they're like they're like you
they have the same problems and they're
[ __ ] trying to do [ __ ] and it's the
american setting
and i remember what it was like back
even though that's my [ __ ] dad's
generation
but i i still
spielberg was really good and that's
what made jaws one great
and the reason why jaws two three and
four weren't that good because that's
not spielberg
yeah they were close but they just and
like i said the thing about it and we've
talked about this before like any time
you're doing a sequel you're just you're
taking the cool idea the lightning in a
bottle that made the first one so
awesome it's like this fresh idea that
came out and then you're just like doing
more of that so to an extent it's going
to be a retread and it's just kind of
like it's too hard to sort of thread the
needle between
more of the same or going so far out
there that like people are gonna be
turned off because it's not what they
wanted yeah so
you know and like i said the more you go
on like the more you have to demystify
things like you have to you have to go
bigger you have to go more impressive
and it's like a lot of times that takes
away a lot of the appeal of the original
so because you know like i said like
jaws the original one yeah you saw the
shark but you didn't really see the
shark until the end and i know that that
wasn't entirely on purpose like most
people know because it was because the
shark broke so they didn't show it as
much but that ended up working in the
movie's favor
but like the more it went on they
probably thought we needed to be bigger
there need to be like more shark attacks
we need to see the shark more we need
the shark to explode again we need like
this that and the other thing and it's
like the more that goes on it just gets
like stupider and stupider and more
ridiculous and it's just kind of like
you know diminishing returns like as it
goes on so by the time they got to jaws
the revenge
basically they gave it to the guy it's
the same guy that directed his name's
joseph stark he's a good record he's a
good director yeah he's the same guy
that did white lightning the reynolds
movie um he did nightmares that horror
anthology which i still want to rewatch
one of these days uh he did the taking
of pelham one two three so basically
they came to him and offered it to him
and said hey
um we need this movie in nine months
start to finish oh man which is nothing
like there wasn't even a finished script
yet that means pulling out your ass
pretty much and he was and they told him
they said well you can do whatever you
want or whatever and he's just like okay
well you guys need a miracle i guess i
can do it so they did it like i said
they didn't have a finished script and
he's like well what are we gonna do like
to make people wanna sit through
this shark [ __ ] again i mean he didn't
say that but like to get it like to get
interesting so he's like maybe we can
add like magic like i said like adds
like a paranormal element
but
i don't know if it was me like i said i
think that's a stupid idea
now if you're gonna have if you really
want to focus on the brody family again
because it's like you know this is the
family that everybody's followed through
the whole thing and it's kind of like
the part of the franchise if you really
want to do it this is what i would have
done and i just like totally pulled this
out of my butt like 10 minutes ago so if
you really wanted the family to attack
or the the family to attack the shark
well you know i guess that works too but
like um the shark to attack the same
family again which like i said you know
already like people are being like no
that's i mean what are the odds
so i would have it that you know they
got [ __ ] up by sharks last time and
they're like all right [ __ ] this we are
moving to the midwest where there is no
ocean for thousands of miles and then
they get in a plane either that or
they're going like on a vacation
somewhere and then they get in a plane
and the plane crashes into the ocean and
then they get get washed up on like a
deserted island and then that's
surrounded by sharks okay at least that
that's not credible either but at least
it's more
credible than
hey um i don't want to be around the
water anymore oh let's go to the bahamas
which is [ __ ] surrounded by water
oh but great white sharks never come
here i'm like give me a [ __ ] break
with that the idea that a shark would
remember that or would know that its
ancestors were attacked
and now he has to [ __ ] avenge itself
against the descendants of the attackers
no that would never happen and like
sharks are mindless pre-pee brains
yeah i think a lot of people and like i
said if you're gonna do that in a movie
lean into it make it a comedy make it
ridiculous make it like sharknado or we
just shark or something we'll make it
better
make it better than we just yeah but i
mean that was only the price that was a
good idea only the premise of weekly
shark was good i mean they [ __ ] it up
because it cost like a buck 50 to me
yeah but um but yeah sorry you guys but
it's just
it was a good idea though but the thing
about it is that
i just
you just can't have a premise like that
that's supposedly grounded in reality
and like i said this is a completely
serious movie there's like you know the
the sun like gets eaten like in the
first 10 minutes or something like that
and then like for the whole rest of the
movie like mrs brody is just like
[ __ ] crying and grieving and [ __ ]
like that because her son got eaten by a
shark and we're supposed to take all of
this seriously but then on the other
hand we're supposed to believe
that this particular shark for whatever
reason because all the other sharks that
[ __ ] with them before are dead because
that's what happened at the end of all
the other ones but it's so now we're
supposed to believe that this shark that
i guess is related to those what other
reason would he have but like i said i
think that i think it was supposed to be
like a voodoo curse
like a voodoo die like he put like they
pissed off some voodoo priest or
something like that he's like [ __ ] i'm
gonna make a shark like come after you
or something like that which like i said
that's stupid too but
at least it gives it like some kind of
at least it gives it some kind of like
reason there's no reason that this shark
swims all the way down to the bahamas
and goes after this one particular
family
there's just no reason and there's no
reason for her to have a psychic link
with the shark like to know
what it's doing
and that to know that the the shark like
immediately after her son gets eaten she
knows oh it's targeting him specifically
like it came afterwards it just starts
to go down the same road as the um the
exorcist
[ __ ] franchise
where it kind of gets ridiculous up
until [ __ ] uh
until it's really not the exorcist
anymore
uh and it actually gets better when it's
not the action system or what was that
exorcist three i think or four three
three the one with george these guys
george g scott that was good that's more
of just another movie because that's
kind of that well it kind of it had some
extra sisty [ __ ] in it yeah but it was
more like a serial killer it's like it's
a psychological horror type of thing
which i think was a better way to go
because you're now freeing yourselves
from the limitations of exorcist one
okay you're just saying this is related
to that but not quite okay yeah it's
just kind of off on a little side
which like i said if you wanted to do
that there's ways
to do that but it's just kind of like
going from completely grounded in
reality shark attack movies
and then jumping into
essentially paranormal
you know
waters yeah uh not a great idea it just
like came too much out of
someone's ass and they didn't really
think it through i mean you know to
to be fair to them they didn't really
have a lot of time to come up with
something okay i'll give them that
and the generation of guys that made
this movie they were coming out of the
60s and the 70s where the paranormal was
[ __ ]
something that universities were talking
about so they're like oh yeah she can
predict when it happens no problem
because it's been established in other
movies
it's just it was a movie of its time but
really it's
when i think about it kind of retro this
is 87 yeah i was graduating this year
yeah i was in school yeah was that in
high school yeah 88 you were not no i
was in the la my last year of junior
high okay
i would have started although the weird
thing about this and somebody brought
this up just now
all the other jaws movies were like
summer movies and came out in the summer
and i think this one did too but this
one is inexplicably set at christmas
time yeah so this is technically a
christmas movie i christmas in the
bahamas i graduated this year i would
have laughed at this
i'd have been like everybody kind of
laughed at it even in 1987 yeah on
rotten tomatoes this has zero percent
i looked
but um
but yeah it's even not that bad
i've seen way worse it's like i said i
i'm kind of i've been in the trenches of
shitty movies okay so it's just i'm into
mystery science theater i've seen like
the worst of the worst i have seen and
actually i've seen even seen a lot of
movies that were too bad to go on
mystery science theater there are way
way way way shittier movies yeah than
jaws or revenge yeah it's not that bad
and this and draws the revenge at least
better than three it is a lot better i
will i would argue that it's better than
three yeah
but um like i said part three was a was
a decent idea at least for as far as
sequels go but it was just really poorly
executed like i said the special effects
were [ __ ] it was just kind of like it
wasn't great had you taken this movie
and taken the jaw's name off of it and
made it an all-new shark movie they
would have liked it better
they would have liked it better
because it would because you'd be
establishing a new mythology new
mythology you wouldn't it's like oh in
this movie universe right you know
people have
magical shark sense yeah particularly
insert your ass super smart and [ __ ]
like that yeah what was that one what
was that one movie
[ __ ] there was actually a shark movie
that had like super intelligent sharks
but it was explained in universe what
the [ __ ] was the name of that thing i
know i saw it it wasn't great but it was
all right but it was um i think there
was more than one now that i'm thinking
about it but it was explained as like
they were experimenting on sharks so
they were like more intelligent than
normal so like i said that's all you'd
have to do is do some [ __ ] like that
like you said because it was jaws yeah
people didn't buy it because it's like
look none of this nonsense happened in
the other jaws what are you trying what
are you trying to pull right
right you don't have psychic links with
the sharks like the shark isn't coming
to get you and it like swims 1200 miles
in three days i would have never called
this jaws yeah which would have freed
you up to write lucy thank you and it
would have freed it would have freed
them up to write a script that didn't
have to conform to the jaws universe and
the movie would have been good would
have been good
danny rowling said tom put on the curly
michael kane
trying to get me to [ __ ] you should
have thought of that before we started
time for that kind of [ __ ] man the
show's almost over they're trying to get
me to put wigs on so [ __ ] late we
haven't even talked about michael caine
like in this movie i actually do like
michael michael kane was drunk in this
movie playing a drunk michael kane and
he did it by getting drunk
method acting
okay i'm looking
he's protect
he's in a scene where he's supposed to
be drunk at the [ __ ] club and [ __ ]
and i'm looking at jenny that goes that
[ __ ] is drunk he's actually that
[ __ ] is drunk and he is humility
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
because kane kane was he kane knew how
to live in the movie industry make sure
they [ __ ] give put you up in a good
hotel you have all this [ __ ] you know
what i mean you make sure everything's
air-conditioned he got to have a
vacation in the moment that's right
that's right you had to make sure that
they take care of all this [ __ ] and that
you can drink while you're on the job
and [ __ ] you know
kane kane was a good [ __ ] great
british actor
who uh was a gift to america
there's a lot of british actors that
[ __ ] did very well in american movies
and the british actors were were better
than a lot of your american actors
because you know they have a better
theatrical um heritage
uh they go to acting school and actually
learn how to act you know do shakespeare
and [ __ ] like that
and uh that's not really how american
actors happen american actress not
usually i feel like the best american
actors are usually ones that start out
on the stage yeah right they start off
on broadway or something you know and
then not always i mean that's a very
broad statement average american actor
starts off in an orgy or a cocaine deal
that's [ __ ] really well those [ __ ]
[ __ ] kind of come into the who's
screwing who and who's got drugs and
that's how you get into the [ __ ]
acting business in in in old hollywood
um but no the british always brought a
lot of skill to the table
and [ __ ] kane kane was [ __ ] he's a
legend
i grew up watching that [ __ ] i
was scared of him as a kid because he
he he there was a certain underlying
hostility underneath him i can see uh
i think he first made an impression on
me in the in the oliver stone movie the
hand which you know if you're a listener
regular listener to the show i'll talk
about the hand all the time
and uh the hand was a deep flick it's
very deep horror movie
and uh michael caine was always very
impressive to me
and
in this movie he's coasting through it
he's just going well this was during the
era where well i don't know if i want to
say that because he was in some good
[ __ ] he won some oscars right around
this time but um
this is one of his what he what they
call the his paycheck pictures
where and he didn't really give a [ __ ]
like i said he's like hey i get to go to
the bahamas and he's not like he's a
main character but he's not like you
know in a lot of the scenes he's kind of
like a supporting character
and you know and he just gets to have a
good time and honestly he said one of
his famous quotes i think this is even
on wikipedia was that um he's like yeah
it was like a fun movie to shoot or
whatever and he's just kind of like i'm
paraphrasing but he says i i've never
seen the movie but i've heard it's
terrible but
but i but i see the house that it bought
me which is
fantastic he's just like basically yeah
it bought a house and the thing about it
too was that the
in 1986 he was in the movie hannah and
her sisters and he got an oscar for that
like for best supporting actor and he
couldn't go
to california to pick up the oscar
because he was in the bahamas shooting
this yeah so i thought that was kind of
i totally agree with you michael caine
that's how i would have played [ __ ]
80s [ __ ] hollywood i mean he never
watched it he just did it like to get
paid get paid get paid by the house and
then he ended up in the batman series
knocked it out of the [ __ ]
that's what i mean you know what kind of
makes me sad
the best alfred yeah was michael caine
you know what kind of makes me sad
though is that you know i mean michael
kane like obviously like jumped back
from it and like i said he was in good
movies around the same time this came
out too so it's not like he was just
like in a bunch of schlock yeah sadly
though this i think was lorraine gary's
last movie
um now she said that she was very
excited to work with michael caine and
she said that he was just a really
really nice person he was a professional
yeah
yeah she said he was like a super super
nice person but i will say
that he's
it was michael the character in this
he's just kind of like
he's like flying the plane right yeah
and then he's kind of like going after
the mom
later on so it's like she's like the the
romantic interest
he
flies the plane what he lets the little
girl fly the plane he's like oh we're
gonna crash you better do it i'm like
[ __ ] if you did that when i was
in a plane i would be really really
upset and then like when he gets
uh mrs brody up in the plane he's like
i'm just gonna sit here and do that i'm
gonna let you crash in the ocean you
better [ __ ] flat and again i'd be
like look i'm so i'm punching your left
hand as a 53 year old american
the two greatest british actors that
influenced my generation you know what i
mean me personally was [ __ ] michael
kane and oliver reed those two
[ __ ] right there boy they were
legends
both of them you could tell they were
[ __ ] drunk okay
yeah well oliver reed scared the [ __ ]
out of me man he just did he was but but
so so did so did so did michael caine
they scared me but i liked him
they were
in in a lot of the roles that i
remembered them from they were they they
were like they were one or two drinks
away from beating your ass
okay they were kind of intimidating guys
i liked them though [ __ ]
don't ever [ __ ] don't ever let
anybody tell you that you shouldn't
scare small children no scared small
children they [ __ ] love it they grow
up for and remember all kinds of [ __ ]
but michael caine in the hand and the
[ __ ] the island oh man i was very
impressed i mean you have to like never
read not all kids are the same but most
kids being included i love these kids
really really like scary movies yeah i
mean yeah anything and even like movies
for kids that had scary [ __ ] in them
like stuff like yeah you know like the
dark crystal and stuff like that man i
was all about that one yeah
you know what i mean um
danny rowling said uh what's tomorrow's
a haunting episode going to be when you
get a chance i'm not actually sure
because i think i have four or five ever
watching tonight that you guys have uh
recommended so it might be
maybe darkness follows or echoes from
the past or maybe the legend trippers i
don't know like there's so there's a
couple ones that people have recommended
so we haven't decided yet but i was
gonna say uh does hoagie aka michael
caine's character survive in the film
yeah everybody does um there's a great
scene even like roger ebert pointed this
out like back in 1987 when this movie
came out so
michael caine he lands in the ocean like
in the plane because they go out there
to get it's a long story he goes out
there to get mrs brody because she's
gone out in the boat with no weapons or
anything like to feed herself to the
shark and like hope he chokes on her i
don't really know what the [ __ ] her plan
was but so anyway he goes out there on
the plane they land the plane in the
water and then like the shark comes and
like tries to eat the plane so for a
little while you're like oh no michael
caine's dead or whatever and then but
he's like oh no i'm fine you know
whatever his without explaining anything
and he climbs up over the side of the
boat and his [ __ ] shirt is completely
dry
it was like all they had to do was like
hose him down for a second seriously
oscar perez is in there saying who would
be afraid of [ __ ]
michael kane you know what i mean
thinking you know uh
oliver reed yeah but not michael caine
see the oliver stone movie the hand and
then you'll understand i was [ __ ]
terrified
of [ __ ] all
[ __ ] michael cave michael kane was
and michael kane played other roles too
he played assassins and [ __ ] in some of
the british movies
michael caine could play a bad guy there
but there isn't a very sinister
undertone
to michael caine's
delivery
in a lot of [ __ ] especially if you've
seen
the hand
yeah i mean he usually plays like really
good bad guys i think who does what he
plays really good bad guys really good
bad guys
and and a dude who's just [ __ ] insane
see the hand and you'll understand
really good and that's it's a really
good writing in the hand
but um another thing too that was kind
of [ __ ] up is okay the end of this
so mario van
peebles look i mean he legit gets eaten
okay he gets eaten at the end of this
[ __ ] movie all right the shark comes
out well he's trying to put the
whatever technology doodad like in the
shark's stomach and of course he has to
go right to the end of like the bow of
the boat or whatever and he's like
putting it down there with a pole and
then like a dumb ass falls like directly
into the shark's mouth the shark like
chomps down goes down in the water [ __ ]
like that you're like okay that
motherfucker's dead there's blood
everywhere he looked like he got bitten
in half okay
so then
later on like after he was like oh no
[ __ ] the the fake the fake jamaican
is dead but there's that whole thing but
then like a few minutes later he kind of
comes swimming back and he's he's not
fine but
he's like fine enough to be like
fine you know what i mean like i was
like [ __ ] you got bitten in half i saw
that [ __ ] okay like you don't see it see
it but it looked like he had bit in half
right so i kind of feel like what
happened was that maybe the original
ending i'm not entirely positive about
this but i think the original ending had
him just like oh well that dude's
[ __ ] dead um but then like test
audiences were like no we like the the
fake fake and fake and making jig making
we like that guy so they had to like
make it so he survived so that seems a
little
implausible i'm just gonna say it seems
really implausible considering like what
they showed and like how like he would
have bled out i'm sorry he would have
bled out he looks like he was just the
shark had him in the mouth
like that like in the middle and there
was blood everywhere and he went down
and then it was like
a long time and then like oh finally
he's oh i'm fine i'm just like that's
[ __ ] right there you were dead
so you know die but it so there was that
and also i think the original ending
was you know they had like the what the
[ __ ] was that thing where they had like
two of the they look like flashlights to
be honest and it's probably what they
were but they were supposed to like
piss the shark off by
making some kind of frequency that the
shark didn't like or something so they
had one in his tummy and then they had
one on the boat
and then
so when they turned that one on it like
would go boo-boo like in the shark
stomach and then the shark would be like
no then it would roar which sharks don't
roar okay but whatever they don't even
have like vocal cords so it's like raw
and i'm just like come on yeah but it's
got a roar for the boots it's not like a
[ __ ] it's not like a [ __ ] cartoon
sound like a cartoon dinosaur like i was
just like just stop it stop it sharks
will make that noise so
but he's just like it's so funny though
like when you see the shirt come out of
the water like
it's like i just laughed my ass off but
yeah so it does that
and then like it comes to the boat and i
think in the original ending
like they just speared it like with the
with the bow thingy like on the end of
the boat right and they impaled it and
then like the it thrashes around and
starts dying and then the boat kind of
falls apart and people are like oh [ __ ]
we don't have a boat anymore and then
but the shark's dead right now i think
the test audiences didn't like that
um i don't know if it was just because
it wasn't it didn't have enough oomph or
it was too implausible so they said well
let's make it even more implausible
we'll have the thing impale the shark
but then it will blow up
for no reason
yeah why does the shark blow up and then
they don't even do they it's about
something he had on the end of that damn
i thought no it wasn't that it wasn't an
explosive it wasn't explosive okay but
but see if he wanted to make the shark
explode
then why don't you have that being
explosive it wasn't it was just some
kind of thing that like [ __ ] with it
was like a frequency type of thing that
was like pissing the shark off they're
in there [ __ ] would be about [ __ ]
watching the hand and [ __ ] and
oscar's going okay i'm watch the hand
and somebody else said that i should be
a promoter if you want to understand why
it's the hand okay yeah oscar watch the
hand it's uh it's an oliver stone movie
okay in his early years
it's oh yeah what was it 78 yeah that's
a great horror movie about [ __ ] no maybe
it was early 80s we're not sure if it's
about psychokinesis or just insanity or
whatever
and it's michael caine
it and it's during the time when oliver
stone
is working with john milius coming up
with this script for conan one
okay
and uh
michael caine plays an artist who is
drawing
a cartoon that's kind of like conade
but kane is the exact opposite of the
[ __ ]
the masculine morality that's in conan
one
it's toxic masculinity not [ __ ] and
the the hand is about a [ __ ] who
has internalized toxic masculinity to
the maximum okay which is the opposite
of conan conan is not toxic masculinity
it's [ __ ] positive masculinity okay
so just see the movie you'll you'll
understand you'll understand it
it's a great movie
and forgotten
i got that [ __ ] on [ __ ] dvd it is a
little bit forgotten and i haven't
special i remembered it because it
scared the [ __ ] out of me because i
thought when i saw it as a kid and it
scared us
well i think the main thing that scared
me about it is because when i was a kid
and even now like not so much nowadays
but when i was a kid one of the things
that scared me the most was
heads and limbs getting cut off like
that really really bothered me a lot
like but i still wanted to see it but
yeah i thought it was really scary so
like the whole scene in the omen where
david warner gets his head taken off by
the pane of glass that used to scare the
crap out of me oh my god they used to
stress me out so much so because of the
hand like he gets his hand cut off and
then like that whole scene made me keep
my hands and arms inside the car at all
times like after that the hand is almost
like a cronenberg movie
uh similar
better it
i want to say better
different different
stop eating the tablespoon chewing on
the [ __ ] table pookie she's eating
the furniture
she's eating the furniture yeah uh oscar
said damn jenny do that roar again yeah
it's so great though we were watching it
again last night and it's like i didn't
even feel that good but i was like
watching the movie and i just like
busted up laughing because you can kind
of see
the shark like they cause like i said
they have the um the flashlighty doodad
like whatever technology that it's
supposed to be like i guess it's pissing
the shark off like it's some kind of
like frequency that's coming from inside
its belly that's relating to this other
flashlighty thing that they have so they
they do it like they turn it on and then
like far away you see the little sharks
like come out of the water and he's like
i was just kind of like oh my god that's
so [ __ ] great but yeah so i was gonna
say that after the shark
inexplicably explodes there is no
there's nothing explosive i thought
there was some explosive there wasn't no
you're thinking of the first movie
because in the first movie i saw him
where he goes smile you son of a [ __ ]
and then which is so [ __ ] great oh
and that's another thing they actually
show
that scene
with you know with brody it from the
original movie
like with the gun going smiling
and then like shooting it but they play
it like a flashback yeah that ellen is
having that ellen that's her name right
um mrs brody that she's having she
wasn't there she didn't see that yeah
like how is she having a flashback to
[ __ ] she didn't think another thing that
was [ __ ] awesome is that they blow up
the shark
and then the jamaican dudes who
obviously showed you get swallowed by
the shark floats to the surface i just i
was just going on a whole job about that
clearly you were in the back so you
saved him like jonah and the whale what
happened that [ __ ] got bit in half it
looked like he got bitten yeah yeah yeah
i liked it though that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
hilarious it's like yeah we're gonna
bring you like this character we're
gonna bring that's what i said i said
everybody was like no we like you we
like the females they saved you they
saved it for bacon it's just the for
making jamaica
i guess he's a bahamian but let let an
african-american be african
they should have made that [ __ ]
from detroit
it would have been even more effective
okay
that actually probably would have been
better it would have been better yeah
but that's we'll see that's the thing so
then yeah so she's having flashbacks to
[ __ ] she didn't see right so
i mean in the first movie he made the
shark like swallow like an explosive
like oxygen tanks or something like that
which is explosive and then he shot into
the shark's mouth so it blew it up so
you know they've done that and i know
they've done it on mythbusters that
doesn't really happen okay but at least
it's like plausible this one there was
no explosive anything like at any point
in this in this chain of events so
there's no reason why the shark should
have exploded so it's bad enough they
made the shark explode when there was no
reason for it to explode
but the shot they showed
of the like blowed up shark like
floating down in the water yeah that was
the same exact they stole the footage
from the first one
yeah it was the same exact i saw like a
video that showed them right side by
side i'm like that is the exact same
footage those [ __ ] now like i
said to be fair they did only have nine
months
and it's not just nine months to like
make i mean nine months
to write the script do the
pre-production do the actual filming do
the post-production like nine months it
has to be out
and they said all the other jaws movies
took like two years okay so that's what
the comparison we have made quick so
there yeah so they're just like well
what footage do we have that we can
recycle and maybe nobody'll notice
because it's been like a bunch of years
but nowadays everybody notices because
everybody like picks that [ __ ] apart but
you know what i mean yeah so
i don't know man
it's it's fun to watch
although i will say that
a lot of the drama like i know what they
were going for they were trying to go
back to the character like the character
drama from the first movie
and
but i just it wasn't like real effective
like a lot of the character stuff they
did in it was either really boring or
bizarre like what was up with like with
the son michael and the wife
and her be like the weird conversations
they had like what's the about the whole
fight about him taking out the garbage
and then she was gonna like singed his
face off with a blowtorch yeah what was
that all about i don't know there were
there was stuff in this movie where i
was i was getting bored
yeah i think a lot of the character
stuff i mean the characters and it's
fine like the actors were fine
i think a lot of it was like the writing
and the concept um you know i'm not
[ __ ] on the actors because all the
actors seemed to be filler it did yeah
it did and that's like i said that's i
get what they were going for because the
first jaws movie actually did have a lot
of character drama there was a lot of
stuff that you know that wasn't the
shark that was a lot of the characters
interacting and it wasn't bad filler it
was actually pretty good the way it was
filmed and what but the thing is he
didn't care
this is not really pertinent to this
[ __ ] shark story right they're trying
to give you some shark action you didn't
come for a romance you didn't come for
all this other [ __ ] yeah i didn't need
the whole thing about like they're
like the michael and his wife like their
weird
thing and i didn't really need the
romance between michael caine and
mrs and brody's widow i you know i
didn't really need that like that that
wasn't too much of that it was fine but
a lot of the character stuff just wasn't
that interesting and like i said i'm not
[ __ ] on the actors because the
actors all did fine but it was just kind
of like that a lot of it just didn't
need to be
there
um jeffy art said that roar was a stock
sound i heard from many cartoons in the
80s watch any episode of classic he-man
it did kind of sound familiar to be
honest like i said it was just one of
those ones that
just one of those ones that well we we
need to cobble this movie together as
quickly as possible and like i said
it did make money i think it only cost
25 30 million to make and it made like
60 million back so it did make its money
back they did what they were supposed to
do so it did what it was supposed to do
so
so nothing was learned
you know what i mean they're like hey it
was shitty but yeah everyone [ __ ] on it
like i said even back at the time
uh
everybody [ __ ] on it it got zero good
reviews now i did see one i was watching
a couple other uh reviews of it earlier
and most people were just like having
like a good time because it's ridiculous
but there was one guy that kind of made
a good point he's like i'm not saying
this is a good movie he's like you know
it's not it's like has a ridiculous
premise and all this other stuff he's
like but i would argue that it is worth
watching because he's like it
it's leaning into the premise that he's
like the first jaws movie
it's like they it's not usually uh sold
like this but the first jaws movie is
absolutely a monster movie but they're
trying to sell it as kind of like you
know it's nature run amok kind of thing
he's like this movie is just taking that
premise hey it's a monster movie and
just like
putting that out there he's like
obviously this is a monster it's a you
know yeah it's a shark it happens to be
a shark but it's also
intelligent and it can do all these
other things it kind of has magic powers
like a little bit too so he's like so
it's almost kind of if you kind of watch
it in that vein then it's not
quite as ridiculous it should have never
been a jaws but like i said i think it
would have been better received yeah if
it wasn't a jaws movie it didn't already
have an established franchise that was
all based in reality when you're going
off into paranormal magic directions
then people aren't going to buy it like
i said if you started a new thing that
had its own mythology then i don't think
anyone would have complained right would
have been better
i mean people would have still
complained i'm not saying there's
there's never a situation who knows
someone doesn't complain maybe maybe it
wouldn't have made as much money but it
will it probably wouldn't have because i
mean jaws was artistically a big name
artistically it'd have been better not
as a jaws movie
yeah i think so yeah
so what uh we should be good huh that
yeah
oh what i was gonna say too was that in
i saw on the wikipedia page and actually
hadn't heard about this but i don't know
if it's ever going ahead steven
spielberg a couple of years back said
that he actually wanted to do a jaws
prequel that was about quint and about
the uss indiana much better and um
actually the guy like robert shaw the
guy that played quinn i mean he's dead
now but his grandson yeah said he wanted
to be in the movie okay as young quint
oh i'd see it and then they were gonna
do the whole thing about you know him
like the story that he told about the
uss indianapolis
eye yeah like steven spielberg said he'd
be interested in doing that so i don't
know so it's going to be like jaws 5 i
guess but it's going to be like
i wouldn't call it jaws at all no i
wouldn't either probably but i mean if
everybody knew everybody knows
would know what it was
but
quinn
yeah and myth legend
[Laughter]
or like a dolls
[Laughter]
watch that [ __ ] i mean [ __ ] man well
quinn is such a such a character that
well he kind of made that movie just to
be honest i mean he did let's be honest
i mean i like everybody in that movie
like richard dreyfuss is great in it
like yeah they're always schneider was
great but really i mean the interaction
between those three guys in particular
was just fantastic that was one of the
best things about that movie i thought
like other than like all the suspensions
yeah it wasn't as shark driven as you
people think it was it's really not
there's a lot of character a lot of had
to do with with [ __ ] quit which like
i said i think that that's
what what jaws the revenge was trying to
do go back to that character drama which
worked so well in the first movie but
they just didn't have enough time
the premise was stupid and it was just
kind of like they didn't i get what they
were going for and i respect that but it
was just kind of like they should have
had more time to work on it i feel like
like to workshop some other ideas
other than
psychic
shark senses and yeah revenge based
animals it's just it's not a good idea
all right so uh so tonight we're going
to
pick probably one of the haunting
episodes that i mentioned earlier i'm
not sure which one yet whichever one we
feel like watching whenever we sit down
to watch some [ __ ] and so tomorrow will
be a haunting monday so that should be
super fun uh so be sure to
come and see us tomorrow and thanks for
hanging out with us today have a good
rest of your weekend you guys and we
will see you guys again tomorrow evening
bye